environnement à présent dans cette
édition du 7 8 du 28 mars les journées
de l'énergie elle débute dès demain y
participent jusqu'à dimanche rte réseau
transport électricité trois sites
ouverts en ile de france dans les
yvelines à saint denis et à la défense
bonsoir delphine porfirio vous êtes chef
du service exploitation à montigny le
bretonneux on va parler de vos portes
ouvertes dans un instant j'en profite
juste pour accueillir aussi sur ce
plateau pascal rodier bonsoir ils sont
sept secrétaire général du secours
populaire pardon des yvelines avec vous
et tout à l'heure nous parlerons de
cette réorganisation de l'antenne de
guyancourt et puis également de l'appel
à bénévoles que vous lancez ce sera dans
un instant tout d'abord concernant rte
pourquoi avoir décidé d'ouvrir vos porte
sur trois sites c'était une obligation
ah non ce n'est pas une obligation ce
sont les journées de l'énergie en fait
qui démarrent à partir de demain qui
sont une initiative en fait de l'état
français c'est un peu l'équivalent des
journées du patrimoine si vous voulez et
ça va marquer l'ouverture de la semaine
du développement durable
donc tous les acteurs de l'énergie en
fait sont invités donc pour les trois
prochains jours à ouvrir leurs portes à
faire portes ouvertes pour découvrir le
monde des acteurs de l'énergie
même si on ne nous a pas demandé
d'ouvrir vos porte donc que c'est
volontaire vous ai gagné quoi au final
et bien tout simplement donc de faire
prendre conscience aux citoyens du débat
sur la transition énergétique c'est
vraiment le lancement de l'occasion de
prendre vraiment le conscience en fait
de ce débat sur la transition
énergétique de la mission de rte c'est
le bon fonctionnement de l'ensemble du
système électrique qui vous regarde mes
notes pour pas me tromper en veillant à
l'équilibré entre l'offre et la demande
dans quelle mesure ça intervient sur
cette question de transition énergétique
alors rte d'abord qu'est ce que c'est
c'est le réseau de transport
d'électricité vous l'avez dit
effectivement donc c'est le réseau qui
transporte l'électricité sont cent mille
kilomètres de lignes donc sur le
territoire français et notre mission
c'est de pouvoir acheminer l'électricité
qui est produite par les centres de
production en france
ensuite de faire circuler cette
électricité pour pouvoir alimenter d'une
part donc les grandes industries la ratp
la sncf également les agglomérations et
la presse sont nos confrères de rdf qui
prennent le relais et qui va ensuite
distribué l'électricité donc jusqu aux
particuliers
donc demain nous sommes enfin ça me déjà
aujourd'hui en fait dans cette
transition énergétique
on nous demande à chaque citoyen en fait
d'imaginer ce que sera le visage
énergétiques de demain
donc en clair où seront situés les
nouveaux centres de production
quel type de centres de production en
fait seront créés en france avec un
grand développement des énergies
renouvelables donc des éoliennes des
centrales photovoltaïques
et si le réseau n'est pas au rendez vous
pour accorder ces nouvelles centrales
dans la transition énergétique ne sera
pas réussie nous sommes un acteur
incontournable de cette transition
énergétique
ils habitent aussi à traverser ces
différentes journées donc dû débuter
demain qui vont se dérouler jusqu'à
dimanche c'est aussi de sensibiliser à
la consommation d'énergie
attention pas attention à leur propre
compte en effet vous avez raison dans la
transition énergétique d'une part on va
définir les nouveaux centres de
production mais d'autre part on va
également donc définir quels seraient
les comportements les meilleurs en fait
en terme de consommation d'électricité
c'est un enjeu de cette transition
énergétique
justement il ya une prise de conscience
ces dernières années ces derniers temps
ces derniers mois peut-être parce qu'on
le voit le temps reste reste froid et il
faut qu'en s'échauffer mais est ce que
pour autant les gens font attention et
bien écouteurs dans a discuté il ya eu
peu de temps sur ce plateau
effectivement ce qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est que chaque jour en fait à 19
heures on a une pointe de consommation
d'électricité c'est le moment où vous
rentrez chez vous vous allumer la
lumière ou mettez en route le four ceara
et en même temps les entreprises les
commerces n'ont pas encore fermé donc
c'est vraiment le moment de la journée
chaque jour où l'on constate un maximum
de consommation électrique
il faut savoir qu'en dix ans cette
pointe de consommation électrique elle a
crû de 25%
donc c'est quand même énorme et il ya
vraiment une prise de conscience à
opérer sur cette pointe de
transformation pour pouvoir déplacer en
fait des usages de l'électricité les
utiliser l'électricité à un autre moment
si c'est possible et permettre de ne pas
avoir ce pic de consommation
d'électricité tous rassemblés sur le
même heure tout l'importance de ces
journées d'énergie pour sensibiliser et
parlé également de cette transition
énergétique
on va parler des différents sites qui
sont ouverts il y en a trois en
ile-de-france juste une parenthèse le
site de montigny puisque vous en êtes
l'une des responsables ne sera pas
ouvert au public 1 alors il ne sera pas
ouvert au public effectivement donc
c'est un site un site qu'on a pu voir en
images et quelques temps aussi sur
téléphiles 78 voix société ouvert au
public alors c'est ainsi qu'ils aient
particulièrement stratégique où on a
besoin de calme et de sérénité pour
faire face aux tous les incidents qui
pourraient qui pourraient survenir
je rappelle donc que c'est un site en
fait c'est vraiment la tour de contrôle
du réseau d'électricité sur paris la
région parisienne et la normandie
ce qui explique qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
être comme il s'appuie sur l'un ou
l'autre des boutons ce serait un petit
peu voir un petit peu compliqué pour les
pour les autres habitants
le site yvelinois qui sera ouvert en
revanche est celui de méré mais ceux qui
vont se rendre là bas vont découvrir
quoi
alors en fait on leur propose deux temps
forts dans cette visite un premier temps
fort pour bien expliquer les enjeux de
la transition énergétique et un deuxième
temps fort pour visiter le poste
électrique donc ce qui est l'occasion de
visualiser à quoi ressemble finalement
un poste électrique c'est un site
important évidemment c'est un site
important puisqu'il de concours en fait
à l'alimentation de la région parisienne
et c'est également un site qui est
intéressant à visiter qui est très
récent d'abord dans coeur je vais vous
donner les vrais sa mére sur le voilà
sur la départementale 9 112
mais si je vous le donne l'adresse c'est
parce qu'il n'est pas facile à voir si
en fait on a on l'a intégré dans le
paysage d'accord donc
voilà on a travaillé particulièrement
donc avec le conseil régional
d'ile-de-france avec kevin environnement
et avec d'autres partenaires à intégrer
ce poste dans l'environnement pour pas
vous perdre aller sur le site internet
de rte pour bien repérer l'adresse sur
google maps aussi ça vous aidera
forcément qui répondra aux différentes
questions des visiteurs justement ce
sont des professionnels des
professionnels de rtl tout à fait qu'ils
travaillent dans les postes électriques
on a cité le site de mairie et sur le
département des yvelines je le disais il
ya 3 citant tour en ile de france
peut-être un mot sur les deux autres
postes qui seront ouverts il ya le le
post scène à saint denis et puis il y en
a également un autre et que dont j'ai
oublié le nom c'est à la défense voilà
c'est la défense là c'est pas un poste
électrique cette fois ci c'est le show
room en fait de rte à la défense qui
permet de voir en fait des applications
un peu futuriste de ce que pourrait être
le réseau électrique de demain et un
mois sur le site de seine sur le site de
seine alors c'est un poste électrique
donc il se trouva en seine saint denis
est donc ce poste là sa particularité en
fait c'est qu'il est intégré vraiment
dans une zone très
organisé en fait donc là c'est un poste
en bâtiment cette fois ci avec avec qui
et des installations qui sont confinés
dans ce poste qui est vraiment au coeur
de ville si vous êtes vraiment passionné
vous pourrez même visité les trois sites
puisque les ouvertures s'échelonne sur v
sur les différents jours du week-end
merci d'être venu et nous en parler je
précise juste que les inscriptions sont
obligatoires
donc il est mieux effectivement d'aller
cendres sur notre site avant pour
s'inscrire si vous souhaitez visiter les
différents sites de rte
au cours de ces journées de l'énergie
merci à vous le secours populaire en
appel aux bénévoles pour relancer
l'antenne de guyancourt pascal rodier
vous allez nous en dire plus vous êtes
en charge de la section des yvelines
nous allons juste regardé un reportage
ensemble pour le moment blue line et à
c'est une plateforme de services
réservés aux personnes en perte
d'autonomie
elle vient d'ouvrir à elancourt elle
propose toute une série des d'une
expérimentation et qui va être menée
auprès de 1500 foyers l'illinois dont un
tiers saint quentinois catherine mulato
david charpentier une balance pour
mesurer l'évolution du poids et
contrôler la dénutrition un bracelet
d'autonomie équipé d'un système gps pour
suivre le malade dans ses déplacements
et éviter notamment les fugues des
personnes atteintes d'alzheimer la
personne s'en va le système déclenche
une alarme locale et sont morts et
ensuite on transmet aussi le système
les aides-soignants l'information de la
fugue voici quelques-unes des solutions
mises en place par l'entreprise blue
line et à dont la plateforme est
implantée à est en cours
un dispositif de bouquets de services
pour garantir le maintien à domicile des
personnes dépendantes saluée par la
ministre déléguée aux personnes âgées
là nous avons l'illustration de piste
pour permettre comme le souhaitent tous
les français le fait de rester à son
domicile en vieillissant nous sommes
dans le champ du mouvement de
l'innovation et je dois dire que je suis
extrêmement heureuse en particulier du
concours entre l'entreprise et les
collectivités territoriales ici qui ont
su se mettre en cohérence et en
convergence avant une commercialisation
complète comptait 69 euros par exemple
par mois pour ce bracelet d'autonomie
dont une prise en charge à hauteur de
40%
une expérimentation va être menée auprès
de 1500 foyers couvrant une large zone
entre versailles grand parc jusqu'à
corbeil essonnes un tiers des foyers
seront saint quentinois
les personnes sont en cours de
recrutement nous on parle pas de
personnes on parle de foyers 1500 foyers
parce que souvent quand on met en place
ce genre de dispositif on permet de
protéger les patients d'assister les
soignants mais aussi d'accompagner les
aidants ce recrutement va se faire par
le biais des communes donc des ccs
déclic des mayas des différentes
structures
bien évidemment nous avons en chef de
file du ps l'institut promotion de la
santé de trappes et puis aussi géré
handicap
le dispositif sera opérationnel dès le 2
avril
quant au gouvernement il lancera le 24
avril prochain la silver economy une
filière pour réunir tous les métiers
liés au secteur de la perte d'autonomie